welcome back to new rock stars it's me
mt and daredevil is highly anticipated
to appear in the new she-hulk series on
disney plus any day now and with the
series show runners promising a much
lighter take on daredevil than what we
will be getting in this solo disney plus
series coming out in the near future a
big question obviously still remains
here what exactly could daredevil even
be doing in this she-hulk show like what
role could his cameo serve to the
overall shield story well apparently a
daredevil villain has been attached to
appear on this show for quite a while
now and it wasn't until just recently
that that fact was revealed and it will
likely be through this daredevil
adversary that both matt murdock and
jennifer walters will first make each
other's acquaintances so let's find out
just who could be behind the wheel of
this green sports car and why both
daredevil and she-hulk could be trying
to stop them shall we but first head on
over to rockstarsmerch.com today so you
can pick up our new latest obsession
shirts and all of our amazing merch over
at new rockstarsmerch.com we sell only
the best high quality nerd [ __ ] so head
on over there today to get yourself
styling in nerd style alright so ever
since she-hulk was even announced
everybody and their mother and their
mother's mother have been praying to see
jennifer walters meet up and possibly
face off against matt murdock in the
courtroom and luckily we can thank the
great green gumby in the sky that we are
likely to be getting just that
especially with the recent surprising
confirmation of a daredevil villain
being involved in an upcoming episode it
sure was a damn surprise to me because
apparently my assumption that the man
the hero the legend frogman himself was
going to be in the she-hulk show there
was an incorrect assumption because
during a recent interview during the
premiere of she-hulk actor brandon
stanley revealed that his character of
eugene patilio is going to be donning
the title of the marvel villain leapfrog
instead of the marvel hero frogman
during his appearances in the series
which is real freaking weird considering
that the character eugene patilio has
only primarily gone through frogman in
the comics this is of course after
stealing his super spring-powered frog
suit from eugene's father vincent
patilio the original leapfrog who after
being a failure of an inventor decided
to strap some springs on some shoes for
the love of robbing jewelry stores
holding blind men hostage and fighting
daredevil which is exactly what leapfrog
vincent patilio did in his first
appearance in 1966's daredevil number 25
and after chasing that slippery green
bastard for a little while daredevil
would of course whoop that bouncing
behind in daredevil number 25 and have
vincent walking his leaping legs to the
courtroom by daredevil number 26 and
what happens in this courtroom in this
issue could very well be the inspiration
for why matt murdock and jennifer
walters will first meet in the mcu
courtroom specifically with leapfrog as
matt murdock's client because my nerd
babies and daredevil number 26 some
dumbass of a comic book prosecutor in
order to prove to the jury that vincent
was actually leapfrogged physically gave
vincent patilio his leapfrog springy
shoes to try on in the courtroom which
naturally was a stupid idea because it
led to leapfrog hopping his amphibious
ass through the courtroom window to make
his escape with the aid of the only
marvel villain that i can think of that
is more ridiculous than him stiltman and
leapfrog would then go on to continue
his criminal career fighting the
defenders iron man and naturally his
original adversary daredevil again
before starting a family and retiring in
shame of his super embarrassing past as
a useless criminal a shame that would
inspire vincent's son eugene to take his
father's leapfrog costume and redeem the
patilio family name as the hero frogman
the clumsiest marvel hero of all time
now guys is there too much fire and
blood in your life have all of your
shirts been reduced to ash by dragon
fire or stained with the blood of your
enemies or do you just want some sweet
house of the dragon merch from epic
heroshop.com well either way epic
heroshop.com has got you covered we just
dropped latest obsession number 20 ash
and ruin for a limited time inspired by
house targaryen sigil this shirt
features a flaming dragon with a sword
through it representing the rift playing
the blondest family on dragonstone and
if you're the type who's all like screw
my family squabbles i'm going rogue well
there's a shirt for youtube it's
particularly apt if you're a badass
moonlit knight but it'll look cool
either way and look if your vibe is less
rampaging swordsmen and more princess
with dragon check out the new hoodie
inspired by japanese wood vlog art the
merge from epic hero shop is super comfy
and an easy way to show off your nerdy
streak without just screaming fire and
blonde everywhere you go because i tried
that once i got arrested the designs
have so much detail in them that you can
practically feel the love radiating off
of the fabric and as a bonus picking up
a piece of epic hero shop merch is the
best way to support the channel and it's
so crazy cool and amazing for us to see
you guys repping all of our merch all
the time it actually makes us feel like
rock stars when we see one of our shirts
out in the wild and when you do wear our
merch be sure to tag at epic hero shop
and use the hashtag real epic hero to
get featured on their page because we
love to show you guys off so head on
over to epic heroshop.com today to pick
up your new game of thrones inspired
shirt or any other of our amazing nerd
merch options over at epicuroshop.com
we thank epiheroshop for sponsoring this
video now given the fact that she-hulk
appears to be introducing the character
of eugene patilio as leapfrog straight
out of the gate makes me think that a
very similar thing happened with eugene
in the mcu with the title of leapfrog
being one that mcugen probably inherited
from his father vincent you know kind of
like how peacemaker inherited the
peacemaker title from his father auggie
over on the dc side of things but
regardless of whether it's for the name
of good or evil i have a feeling that at
some point in the show something is
going to happen where eugene as leapfrog
will be arrested at a crime scene for a
crime that he may or may not have
committed leading to leapfrog getting a
visit from our favorite blind bringer of
justice matt murdock much like matt
showed up for peter parker in no way
home who will serve as eugene's defense
attorney while jennifer walters serves
as eugene's prosecutor forcing the two
marvel heroes to go head to head in the
court of law and then when things seem
like they're not exactly going his way
in the courtroom i can very much see mcu
gene leapfrog doing what comic book
leapfrog did by grabbing his frog themed
gear mid-trial and piecing the frog out
through the window and then choosing a
green sports car as his frogmobile
getaway vehicle with both matt murdock
and jennifer walters now forced to chase
eugene down as their superhero selves to
keep him from evading justice you know
kind of like how she-hulk was forced to
chase down her client arrows in the
comics after arrows didn't exactly like
how the trial was headed like jen and
match do not play with the law they do
not but yeah that's pretty much how i
believe daredevil will connect to
she-hulk in this series like i do not
believe that marvel studios would really
put leapfrog and daredevil in she-hulk
without them factoring into each other
considering how close the leapfrog
character is with daredevil and so much
like the creators have been telling us
for a long while now i would definitely
expect to see a lighter and goofier side
to matt murdock's interesting life in
this series because while daredevil
fights a ton of interesting battles in
the streets and in the courtroom not all
of his rogues gallery are as big time
serious like kingpin or bullseye like
daredevil has got his fair share of
ridiculous villains in his rogues
gallery too and i believe that it will
be through this experience with
daredevil that we could see eugene the
leapfrog eventually attempts to reform
himself as the mcu's fabulous frogman
especially if his suit ends up being
inherited from a villainous leapfrog
like it was in the comics at least i
hope it does because let's face it
leapfrog is a stupid-ass name and i do
not like it frogman all day every day
let's go but anyways thank you guys so
much for watching this video you can
follow me mastertainment on twitter you
want to see me tweet some weird [ __ ] and
really fun and interesting theories but
more importantly you can follow the new
rockstars wherever we are on social
media and of course do not forget to hit
up newrockstarsmerch.com today to pick
up all of our amazing nerd gear for you
or for even your little one because we
got some shirts and stuff that fit kids
now too kids can also be nerds but yes
thank you guys so much for spending time
with me i love you guys so much and i'll
see you guys next time goodbye vlog
squad for life
[Music]
you